MYSELF AND MYRI WANT TO SFO
W
AN HETOLOS
NOT RE
HE SHOULD BE HERE..
HEORLD VERY
LAST  "I CAS
THE WOR HEARDYD CALL OUTFOR HISI
LEAD PROCUN THE MDE  I FOR TORG
THTIGATION ISNGNG KNOW  LOT OF G
EXPERIENCED AM
E N,YTEAM, REVIEWED THE EVIDENC
WIBCMETHING TORENCE IT, THANK Y
SHOW ANDUSTICE
TO MAKE TSE
GH I FILED A THAT FORMER
EAS D IN THE  DEGRER GEOR
I BELIEVE THE EVIDEEILABLE
TOOW STRONGER
ARONEREDD WECOND, TODAY ARRSWEM
THAO.IKEUNCEY,EN COEL  I
AR POLICFI
NE, ANDTHAO, NG MURDE  A
IHESE ARE IN
T
THE INTERESTS OFCE
FLOYD, HISFATHE ATE.
BSOLUTELY A TWENGL, JUSEO
I NT TOIRHENTY ATTORNEY MIKE
FREENPART ITH
WAY.
HIS EXPIE IAV
BEEN INV
IN T
TEAM.
WANTY
ATTORNEYIONALF WHO HAVEOOPERATE
THISE I THANK
SUPERIDE E
BUREAU OF CRIMINAL APPREHENSION
D HIS PROFESSIONAL STAFF FORTH I
INVESTIGATIO IAN TO THANK
cDONALD AND
SPECIALETING A PARALLELAL OIN HE
LESH D
JUSTICE THHEPP LEADERSHIP IN
PURSUIT HER ATION.
WELL, ONEALN.
I AAIAM I THINK I C
SPEAREEMAN AND
ALONGU.S. ATTYcDONALD.
HEPATIENCE IN AG USANR THESECH .
THIS CASE CONTINUESER VEE CLYBOT
IN DEVELOP THE CASE FORECUTION
EVEBOIT,
UR J IS T T ANVTI IN PRESS, BUT
DO OUR TALKING IN COOR
LUBLIC
I
I ALSO A FOR YOU THA BLEGADEETHI
THE INVESTIGATION IS IN A PATH E
STIGATING AS QUICKLY ASNAUSE SPS
WE'RE ALSO INVGHLY AS BECAUSELES
CRALT, BUT IT S
THE ONES I
IMPORTANTSINGLE LEAN SE NEEDS CH
OT BECAUSEOUBT
OUR RESOURCES
IN FACT WE'RE
WE'RE BU HISTORY DOES SHOW THAT
NDAC
AND ISOMMUNITY S
LY
BLO
BEVEIT
NG, IFLOYD HE WAS LOVED.
HISY WRTT.HIS E.
ANCE
AND FOR YOU AND WELIT FACT THAT
THAT SOE SOLUTION WILL
BE ANDK
TRUS
FAIRNESS IN OCIOROR O
WE'T F A OF THAS START THAT WOR
FAITH  C AND
HUMA TO BEGINING THE RULECI
POLICY AND
GI OFHINKING
AT THE MUE,E WORLD OF ARTSENENC
CH NEEDTHERELL A JUSTICEHA
HA EXPERI FINALALYSIS, PCAN SHA
PROTESTS ARE AND JUST INSTI S B
CHHARGESHEIS  WE H
AND SO PUT
W PUTTING
HENEAR FAVOR OF
ANYONERHATH FND
WE'RE GOING TO PURSUE THEM.
>> Repor T HENNEPIN COUNTY
THE FROM HIM.NG TREAT CASE > E
OF WAY.WEOTHER
THESE CHARGES.
WEELRE FREEMAN AND I W'VE COMPLO
>> Reporter: THE WHOLE NATION, S
WAITING FOR SOME TYPE OF  FROMC.
CAN YOU DESCRIBSS
IN D WHAT THINK YOURE JUST IN
MINNEAPOLIS BUTSECOUNTRY RIGHT O
NFTUAN DEL
INTO OUR DERS.
AT I CAN TELLETHERED ALL THE FA
STATUTES, WASELA
SULTED WITH EACH OTHER, IFE
>> Reporter: WHAT DOES T
PA THISSION?
>> THEF JUSTICES
I WAN SIGNA TO THEM
THAT WEOPE THAT THEY O IN A
THEMSELVES.AN SONTINU OWN
IE TOGETHER, TILD A JUST LICE/CN
WE NEED AND E
TO US TDS JUSTE.EE
TO DO THAN
JUST THIPEOPLE
TO DO . INAUD ]
RE WE TALKING
MONTHS?
>> I WANTASPASERO
SEPENS IN A ALINTHOROUGH,
AND I DON'T KNOWMANY,
KE SURET AV FULLY
ATCH GOOIAL, THAO RUSH WHAN DEA
THAT.
IN THE BACK.HE FLO ASKED FOR A
WHILE COMMITTING AN YOU EXPLAIN
INTENTIOL MURD M
YOU HAVE TVE PREMEDITATION
AND DELIBERATIO CHARGE
FIRST-DEGREE MURDER.SE YOU HAVE
TO INTEND FOR DEATH T
D FELONY , I AHET WITHOUTSSARI.
BE --
CONTEN THAT
ASSAULTED THAT -- AND SO
THAT WOULD BE THE NG
FELONY.
>> Reporter: WOULD YOU ACC PLEAO
ANDSECOND T B BE RELEASED?
>>AV WHAT PLEATHAT, IS
WAY O BEG
CONVERSATION
AT THIS POINT,RERE TRYSENG ELSE
AT THIS POINT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PLANS IN THAT DIRECTION. SOT
I DON'T HAVE ANYINEPAT THIS TIM
THE CASE ANDLUSION ABOUT  BELIE
MOST.
THE IL
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.MY DREW EVANS.
I'MNDENT OF THE
MI BUREAU OFRI ENSION.
WE'RE IN THE PSS OF
E RS INTO I CAN REP IUSTODY HETO
orter: IPPENS AFTERIBLE ]?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID,
WE CAN'T SPEAK ABO ALL T
DETAILS IN THE CASETHWHATN THIS
TIME.
I WIL WITHNY ATION, AS I'VE TOL
ALL FROM THE VER WEVE T ITHEBCAI
THIS WITH THERYING  INFOHIS CA
THATSUL ALL
OF OUR INIGATIONS, TOTNTE OFFIC
OVE FORWARD.
eporter: MR.NERAL, ALREADYIDE C.
>>TH
HAM TOWO LIKO JUSTNTS LL,STHGENS
OFFICE HDIVISIONAND LAWYERS TO T
THIS D ALSPEN
HENNEPIN COUNTY ATTORNEY'
WE'RE WORKING THISHI
>> Reporter: [ INAUDIBLE ]
INFORMATIO CHARG
BEFORE T W DID THAT FACO AWEACR
WEAD T BASEDTS THAT GURES.
SO THAT'S  Aeporte [ IT'S GFINE
GREAT.T  TIME INNNINYSALTH ANDYE
FREEMABL] LET THE PEOPLE WHOCUSD
TR WUTE, I'M GOINGO DO TINQUE
A T>> Reporter: THE CHARGES WE
CORREC THREE O FACE
THEERSONALSENTENCE AS OFFICER CA
>> Reporr:POLOGIZE THISBEFORE,
NOW YOU ON THE IN
TERMEG
IN WORKING FOR POLICE
LEGISLATION?E T
DUTIES THAT ICHIVE, WHICH
LO
E VERYCTIVE IN THE
CIVIL
WE'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN ENTING
CONTINUE TO SUPERVISE THAT. I S
DA>> Reporr:AKE
WHEN
DECISIONAS HEREOU
FIRST [ INAUDIBL THE
TREOU SENSE OF
S  S
MOMENT.
I CAN HONESTLY TELLOU IN .ENLIT.
>> Reporter: [ INAUDIBLE ON'T K
>> I WOULD JUST AN
TERMS OF, THAT IS LT TO THEVAS Y
NDTR
GHT NOW IN
THWIES.HOSE ARE DECISNS BASEDSF
AND THEY WORK CLOSELY WITECORRES
CUSTODY WHE
THFE
ASSESSMENTS.
THANYO WIL SHEM THAT I I TO LE
THAT PROVE
IN COURT.
AN  WE DID I'LLPLY SAY THEOP W E
WO WITHHEETH FACT
AND WE
WE BIECARI
[ IN
, BE
COUNTRY HAS UN
THESE MATTERS INNDHOUT THE COUN.
SO T THEST
OFISLLY NOT HOLDIFOR THE
IN SITUATID
SO THANKTHTR
BUT WE C'TOL THE
ALL WE CAN DO
THAT WE H DOST TO THD
>> YOU WERE TO
MINNESOTA ATTORNEY G KEITH
ELLISON, A,INEGREE MURDER HAS B
KNEE ONCK,
KILLING AND CHARG OTH